[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء في حصاد الليله
معكم حسن جامبو
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه الصور من العاصمه
الامريكيه واشنطن هناك اجواء الانتخابات
النصفيه
[موسيقى]
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
خيرسون غموض يتزايد القوه الروسيه تؤكد
قرارها بالانسحاب وبناء خط دفاع على يسار
نهر دنبرو تياف تشكي في الدوافع وتقول ان
القوه الروسيه لم تنسحب من المدينه
وواشنطن تصفه بالانجاز الاوكراني الكبير
انت تم
[موسيقى]
وفي حديث الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا واشنطن
تقول انها لن تزود كياف بمقاتلات او
مسيرات تجنبا للمجازفه بالدخول في حرب
عالميه ثالثه دول البطيخ تتعهد بمزيد من
الدعم حتى انتهاء الحرب والمنسق الرئاسي
الامريكي الخاص يقول للجزيره ان موسكو
تستخدم طاقه سلاحا لكسر الوحده بين واشنطن
واوروبا واسيا
[موسيقى]
وفي الولايات المتحده ترقب مستمر للمشهد
الختامي في الانتخابات النصفيه للكونغرس
على واقع تقدم الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب
وايضا لا يستبعد امكانيه حفاظ
الديمقراطيين على الاغلبيه فيه
منافسه محتدمه في مجلس الشيوخ ونفاده
واريزون وجورجيا تسيطر على مفاتيح الحسن
تزامنا مع اعلان الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه عدم احراز تقدم في المناقشات مع
ايران طهران تعلن عن نجاحها في تصنيع
صاروخ بالسلي تفوق سرعته سرعه الصوت ومدير
الوكاله يؤكد ان الخطوه تعزيز القدر
ورئيسي يقول ان سياسه من سماهم الاعداء في
زعزعه الاستقرار فاشلت مثل فشل سياسه
العقوبات والضغوط القصوى
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه نقشنا التطور اللافت في المشهد
الميداني لحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا الجيش
الروسي يبداوا سحبا جزئيا لقوته من منطقه
خيرسون جنوبيه اوكرانيا في حين اعلنت
قياده سعاده اثنتي عشره بلده في المنطقه
هذا الانعطاف الكبير في مسار الحرب فتح
باب التحليلات بشان اسبابه في ظل الحديث
عن تقدم اوكرانيا في محاوره
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال الثاني كيف يمكن قراءه
القرار الروسي بالانسحاب من
ثلاثه وثلاثون في المئه اعتبروه تراجعا
عسكريا بسبب الخسائر بينما قال 55 في
المئه انها خطوه تكتيكيه واعاده تموضع في
حين راس 12 في المئه انها خطوه تنازلا
روسيه
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز الظاهر على الشاشه لقاؤنا على المنصه
الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرى خلاله لقضايا
مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وتتابعونا في الحصاد ايضا
الصين تكشف عن احدث اصداراتها العسكريه
بمقاتله شبح وتعيد فرض اسئله بشان طموحها
العسكري
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا لا تزالوا ملابسات القرار
الروسي المفاجئ بالانسحاب من مركز مقاطعه
خرسون وكل الاراضي الواقعه شمالى نهر
دنبرو تثير الكثير من الاسئله بشان حقيقه
ما يجري للجيش الروسي على الارض خصوصا في
ظل الاهميه الاستراتيجيه لمدينه خرسون فهي
اول مقاطع
عن انها تعتبر خط الدفاع الاول عن شبه
جزيره القرم وبينما تقول القوات الروسيه
انها قضيه بالقرار واصل كيا في التشكيك
وتقول ان هناك قواتا روسيه داخل المنطقه
بعد نحوي سبعه اشهر من السيطره على مقاطعه
خرسون جنوب الشرقيه اوكرانيا وبعد اقل من
شهر ونصف على اعلان ضمها الى اراضيها تعلن
روسيا انسحاب المفاجئا الى ما وراء نهر
دنبرو تركه خلفها اهم مدن المقاطعه
ومركزها مدينه خرسون تقول موسكو ان الخطوه
تاتي في سياق اعاده تموضع قواتها في ظل
صعوبه تامين خطوط الامداد اللازمه لجنودها
لتمكينهم من الحفاظ والدفاع عن مدينه
خرسون في الاولويه الان بالنسبه الى الجيش
الروسي تحصيل الخطوط الدفاعيه على الضفه
الجنوبيه من النهر استعدادا لمعارك الشتاء
القادم
لطالما اعتبرت خرسون البوابه الاستراتيجيه
لشبه جزيره القرم التي سيطرت عليها روسيا
عام 2014 وهي التي تتحكم بمعظم مصادر
الطاقه ومياه الشرب والزراعه التي تغ قرم
ومنها كانت تنطلق لا سيما في الشهور
الاولى من الحرب الهجمات الروسيه باتجاه
ميكولايف واوديسا لذلك افا ان اضطرار
الجيش الروسي الى الانسحاب منها يعتبر
منعطفا اخر في مسارات الحرب الدائره في
الشرق والجنوب الشرقي لاوكرانيا خصوصا ان
الجيش الاوكراني ومنذ نجاحه في استعاده
السيطره على مناطق خارقيف لا يزال يقاتل
داخل حدود كل الاقاليم الاربعه لوغانس
ودنياسكولوجيا وخيرسون التي سبق واعلنت
موسكو ضمها بشكل رسميا الى اراضيها وان
كان ذلك مرتبط بشكل كبير بحجم المساعدات
الغربيه العسكريه النوعيه التي حصل عليها
في الفتره الماضيه على ان اللافته في موقف
من التطورات الميدانيه في خرسان تشكيكها
في دوافع الانسحاب الروسي قبل ان تقول
لاحقا ان الحديث عن استعاده السيطره عليها
اه لن يكون الا حين ترفرف الاعلام
الاوكرانيه وفوق مبنى المقاطعه مبديه في
الوقت نفسه تخوفها من تحويل الجيش الروسي
لخرسون الى مدينه موت من خلال تلغيم
وتفخيخ كل شيء فيها قبل انسحابه
[موسيقى]
من بيروت معنى العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك سيد الياس
هل من مبررات ميدانيه عسكريه لهذا
الانسحاب الروسي المعلن من الضفه اليمنى
لنهر ديني برو في خيصه
بالطبع حسن هذا الامر اتى على لسان
الجنرال المعين جديدا سيفيكين الذي قال
انه لا يمكن البقاء في هذه المرحله في
خيلسون يعني نتحدث اليوم الضفه الغربيه
حيث الروس هناك مساحه 9000كم مربع تقريبا
فيها ما يقارب ال 20 الى 25 الف جندي لا
يمكن الدفاع عنها لانه طبيعه الارض لا
تسمع بهذا الامر والانسحاب من المدينه لا
يعني الانسحاب من الاقليم لانه بقي ما
يقارب 18,000 كم يعطي مدخل همم الى البحر
الاسود الى
شبه جزيره قرم وبالتالي تامين المياه كما
تم الحديث عنه اعتقد هناك تغيير في
الاولويات بالنسبه
للقرار الروسي هذا انسحاب عملاني وليس
تكتيك ولكن قد يكون له مبررات واولويات في
المرحله القادمه حسن همم هل سيكون
الوضع عند الضفه اليسرى لنهر ديني برو
يعني بعد الانسحاب
وبناء خطوط دفاع جديده هل يمكن ان يكون
وضع القوات الروسيه هناك افضل ميدانيا
بالطبع اولا بالمعنى الميداني القدره
الاوكرانيه اليوم مع الصواريخ الجديده
قادره على ضرب كل التجمعات كل مراكز الثقل
ولكن بالحد الادنى نهر النيبرو يامن عازل
طبيعي مهم جدا يحمي القوات الروسيه على
سبيل المثال يتراوح عرض النهر بين ال 400
متر وصولا الى اثنين كيلو متر كوكا وهذا
الامر يعطي مجال اساسي بالاضافه الى هذا
الامر هناك ما يسمى باقتصاد القوى ويجب ان
ننتقل من هذه المرحله حسن الى ذا فروجيا
الى المنطقه الشرقيه الى الدوبامباز يعني
يجب ان نربط هذا ما يحصل اليوم بما قد
يحصل في الشر في المنطقه الشرقيه او
الدمام خاصه
بمخموطوف وكريمينا كل مرتبط مع بعض ولكن
يبقى المرحله القادمه بماذا تاتي من
اولويات الروس
وسؤالي هنا كان سؤالي التالي يتعلق بمنطقه
شرق الاخرى لماذا
القوات الروسيه يعني لم تستطع الحفاظ على
مواقعها كما يبدو في الضفه الغربيه لنهر
ديني برو
وبماذا تختلف هذه الجبهه مثلا على اهميتها
بالنسبه للجانب الروسي عن الجبهات الاخرى
في دونيسك ولجانسك
في المرحله الاولى من الحرب خرسان سقطت
اول اقليم اليوم كان الهدف الانطلاق من
خرسان باتجاه مايكوليف وصولا الى اوديسا
ولكن الامور كلها تبدلت بسبب اخطاء سياسيه
جيوستراتيجيه وحتى في التنفيذ العسكري لها
اسباب اخرى ليس من المجال الحديث عنها
حاليا بعد هذا الجمود لا يمكن بالمعنى
العسكري البقاء في هذه المدينه معزوله عن
الخلفيه الاساسيه حيث اللوجستيه يعني
عندما اتى سلاح الهايمر على سبيل النساء
دمر كل الجسور خاصه ان تنفسكي وحتى منع
الجسور الصغيره من التواصل مع اقليم خرسان
بعبور النهر والوصول الى همم مدينه خسران
فاذا اصبح ما يقارب 30,000 جندي معزولين
عن القاعده العسكريه اللوجستيه الخاصه بها
كل ما يمد بصله من هنا تم نقل هذه القوات
الى المنطقه الشرقيه شكرا لك العمي يسحنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي حدثنا من
بيروت
قال وزير الدفاع
الروسيه نائب وزير الدفاع الروسيه اوليكسي
رزنيكو فان القوات الروسيه ستحتاج اسبوعا
على الاقل للانسحاب من مدينه خرسن وان ذلك
لا يمكن ان يتم خلال يوم من او يومين
واوضح ان فصل الشتاء سيبطئ العمليات
العسكريه ويمنع الطرفين فرصه لالتقاط
الانفاس واضاف ان هناك نحو اربعين الف
عسكري روسي في منطقه
الاستخباراتيه تشير الى انه ما زالت هناك
قوات روسيه في مدينه خرسون والمناطق
المحيطه بها والضفه اليمنى من نهر دنبرو
وتبع ان هذا الانسحاب سيمنح هو الطرفين
فرصه لاعاده نشر الجنود في جبهات اخرى هذا
الكلام هو لوزير الدفاع الاوكراني الذي
استبعد تدمير روسيا لسد كخوفك وقال انها
مجنونه لانها
ستغرق مناطق تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه
كما قال ريزين جوڤ وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
هذا هو تحاول القوات الروسيه سيطره على
مدينه بخموت في شمال مقاطعه دونيتس شرقي
اوكرانيا منذ عده اشهر وابي سبب المعارك
الضاريه التي تدور في محيطها تعاني
المدينه من انقطاع تام في الخدمات
الاساسيه
فالدمار طال اجزاء واسعه منها فريق
الجزيره تمكن من دخول
ورصد الاوضاع الصعبه التي تعيشها المدينه
ومن بقي فيها من السكر
مدينه كان الحياه توقفت فيها هكذا تبدو
مدينه بخمود وقد غادرها معظم اهلها
اصوات القصف لا تكاد تتوقف تذكره بان تم
معارك طاحنه تدور على مشاعرها في هذه
المدينه
والاسواق ومرافق البنيه التحتيه ولم
تستثني حتى ملعبها الرياضيه الرئيسي
لاحق الدمار بالجسور التي تربط شطرين
المدينه وهو ما يجبر كثيرا من بقي من
سكانها على تجشم عناء رحله يوميه محفوفه
بالمخاطر للحصول على بعض المساعدات
الانسانيه من المؤسسات الاغاثيه التي تجرؤ
على دخول المدينه
والاتصالات مقطوعه القصف على مدار الساعه
الوضع صعب وننصح الناس بمغادره المدينه
قبل اشتداد الف فصل الشتاء
في هذه الظروف لم تجد الينا بددا من اعداد
الطعامها على الحطب ترفض مغادره مدينتها
بخمود وترفض الحديث للكاميرا انها لا تريد
ان تتحول الى لاجئتان في هذه السن من
حياتها التقينا اندريه وزوجته الذين خرجان
لتفقد شقق من غادر المدينه من اصدقائهما
ماذا يمكنني ان اقول نعيش وسط اصوات
الانفجارات المرعبه ولدت هنا واريد ان
اموت هنا
توصف جبهه مدينه بخمود بانها اعنف جبهات
القتال في مقاطعه دونيتس الا ان القوات
الاوكرانيه ما زالت تؤكد قدرتها على سد
المحاولات الروسيه المتكرره لاقتحام
المدينه من ثلاثه محاور وقد غدت لا تبعد
عنها سوى نحوي ثلاثه كيلومترات
منذ نحوي اربعه اشهر والقوات الروسيه
تحاول السيطره على مدينه بخمود
الاستراتيجيه لفتح الطريق امامها
تورس المدينهتين
تحت سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه
الدوناتس الجزيره
في روما قال الامين العام لحلفي شمال
الاطلسيه خلال كلمه امام مؤتمر الدفاع
الالكتروني للحلف انه اوكرانيا نجحت في صد
الهجوم الروسي وان الناتو سيواصل دعم له
لها ما دامت الحاجه الى ذلك
يتم تدريبها في المملكه المتحده وهم من
الشباب الاوكرانيين الشجعان الذين يدافعون
عن وطنهم نجحت اوكرانيا في صد الغزو
الروسي من خلال اصدار شعبها ودعم الناتو
سنواصل دعم اوكرانيا ما دام الامر يتطلب
ذلك
قال الرئيس الامريكي جيوبايدين ان بلاده
لن تجازف بالدخول في حرب عالميه ثالثه من
خلال توفير مقاتله امريكيه لاوكرانيا
واضاف ان واشنطن ستقدم لاوكرانيا القدرات
المعقوله للدفاع عن نفسها
اوكرانيا
الكثير من الاشياء ولكننا لم نقدمها لها
على سبيل المثال العامه
ونواجهها ونشتبك مباشره مع مقاتله الروسيه
ولكننا سنوفر الاوكرانيين القدرات
المعقوله الدفاع عن انفسهم
واخذنا كل الصحيفه عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان
البنتاجون رفض تزويد اوكرانيا بمسيرات
عسكريه متطوره خشيه التصعيد الصراع او
استهداف مواقع على الاراضي الروسيه كما
اشار المسؤولون الامريكيون للصحيفه الى
مخاوف من وصول التكنولوجيا المتطوره
للطائرات المسيره الى ايضا غير مرغوب فيها
حسب تعبيرهم
تعاهدوا وزراء دفاع دول القوات
الاستكشافيه المشتركه لدول البلطيق بدعم
اوكرانيا عسكريه وماديا الى حين انتهاء
الحرب الروسيه عليها من خلال ما يعرفوا
بصندوق دعم اوكرانيا واقل الوزراء عقب
اجتماعيا
خسيره الحرب في اوكرانيا استراتيجيا
واعتبر الوزراء ان روسيا ما زلت تعتبر
تهديدا لدول المجموعه في المستقبل المنظور
وقال وزير الدفاع البريطاني على سؤال
للجزيره ان روسيا قوضت جيشها واقتصابها
وتواجه عزله دوليه بسبب شنيها هذه الحرب
في اوكرانيا واضاف ان روسيا تخسر الحرب في
اوكرانيا وانها خسرت 100,000 من جنودها
منذ بدء الحرب
دوليا
في صفوفه نتيجه القياده السيئه وبساله
القتال الاوكراني دعنا نكون صريحين لم يكن
احد يظن اننا سنقف هنا اليوم لنقول ان
اوكرانيا تجبر روسيا على التراجع وقد
اعلنت روسيا انها ستتخلى عن هدفها الوحيد
الذي استولت عليه
وفي واشنطن قلى المنسق الرئاسي الامريكي
الخاص عنه سوكتين ان روسيا فشلت في تحقيق
هدفها الرامي الى استخدام الطاقه كسلاح
وكسر وحده الولايات المتحده واوروبا واسيا
واضاف اوكستين في لقاء خاص مع الجزيره ان
ذلك لم يحصل لان واشنطن عملت عن كثب مع
دول مثل قطر للحصول على امدادات بديله
استخدام الطاقه الكسلاح الرئيسي لتفكيك
وحده الولايات المتحده واسيا والعالم لم
ينجح ذلك
عن كتب مع دول مثل قطر التي ساعدت حقا في
التاكد من وجود امدادات بديله للغاز
الطبيعي والغازال وقمنا بزياده امدادات
الغاز الطبيعي المثال بشكل كبير من
الولايات المتحده الى اوروبا وقامت قطر
بقدر هائل من العمل وكذلك النروج وتبدل
جهود كبيره للتاكد من ان العالم مزود بشكل
جيد وقد شهدت اسعار الغاز الطبيعي انخفاضا
كبيرا بلغ 70% وسنواصل العمل لخفضه اكثر
[موسيقى]
تتواصل عمليات وفرز الاصوات في الانتخابات
النصفيه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
واشارت اخر الارقام الصادره حتى الان الى
تقدم الحزب الجمهوري في مجلس النواب
واحتدام المنافسه في الشيوخ حصل
الجمهوريون على 49 مقعدا مقابله 48
للديمقراطيين في مجلس الشيوخ ويحتاج كل من
الحزبين الى الظفر بمقعدين اضافيين على
الاقل كي يتمكن من الحصول على الاغلب
وستحدد نتائج ولايات نيفادا واريزونا
وجورجيا من سيفوز بالمجلس في حين ستجرى
جوله ثانيه من الانتخابات في جورجيا بعد
فشل المرشحين الديمقراطي والجمهوري في
تخطي حاجز الخمسينات في المئه
ولم يستبعد الرئيس الامريكي امكانيه
الاحتفاظ حزبه بالاغلبيه في مجلس النواب
رغم خساره عدد من المقاعد وعرب بيض عن
استعداده للعمل مع الجمهوريين بغض النظر
عن نتائج الانتخابات
بالاغلبيه الديمقراطيه في مجلس النواب
وبغض النظر عن نتيجه الانتخابات النصفيه
الموجه الحمراء التي تحدثت عنها وسائل
الاعلام لم تتحقق وقد بعث الامريكيون
برساله لا غموض فيها اثادها انهم يريدون
حمايه الديمقراطيه وحريه الاختيار مثلما
عبروا عن ما يشغل بالهم من امور المعيشه
والامان
واو
ما معنى من نيفادا مراسل الجزيره فادي
منصور فادي اخر المعلومات بشان نتائج
الانتخابات في نيفادا
نعم حسن حتى هذه اللحظه المرشح الجمهوريه
لمنصب مجلس شيوخنا في ولايه نيفادا ادم
زال يتقدم على عضو مجلس الشيوخ قد
الديمقراطي هذا المقعد يحتله الديمقراطيون
كافرين كورتاز ماستو بنحو 15000 صوت بعد
ان تمكنت ماستوا خلال ساعات الماضيه
تحديدا ليله امس من تقليص هذا الفارق لكن
هناك تطورات مهمه حصلت خلال ساعتين
الماضيهتين داخل الرئيس دونالد ترامب على
الخط وعلى التابرا ان نظام الانتخابات هنا
في هذه المقاطعه مقاطعه كلارك حيث توجد
مدينه لاسفاجاس وهي خزان الاصوات والتكتل
البشريه الاكبر في ولايه نيفادا قال ان
النظام الانتخابات فاسد وهذا ما استدعى
ردا من السلطات المقاطعه التي اعتبرت ان
الرئيس دونالد ترامب غير مطلع على
القوانين ويبدو انه بعد عامين لا يزال
يكرر نفس التصريحات يبدو ان لن نعرف حقيقه
من سيفوز بمقعد مجلس الشيوخ في هذه
الولايه حسن ربما حتى يوم السبت لماذا لان
هناك تحديدا في هذه المقاطعه اكثر من
50,000 صوت وصلت بالبريد ستقوم المقاطعه
بفرزها اليوم ويوم الجمعه وصولا الى ليله
السبت هذا من ناحيه وبالتالي الفارق بين
الاصوات بين المرشحه الديمقراطيه عضو مجلس
الشيوخ ومنافسهم جمهوري اصغر من ما تبقى
من اصوات وبالتالي يمكن للمعادله ان تنقذب
مره اخرى ثانيا ان هذه المقاطعه مقاطعه
كلارك التي لا تزال فيها الاصوات الاكبر
عاده ماتميل باصواتها لصالح الديمقراطيين
في حين ان مقاطعات الارياف تميل لصالح
الجمهوريه اضافه الى ال 50,000 صوت هناك
نحو اكثر من اثنين 10,000 صوت من الاصوات
المؤقته والتي ينبغي ان يتم تصحيحها وهذه
القوانين الولايه لا يمكن ان نعرف فحواها
لمن اقترحت حتى يومين الاثنين والاربعاء
المقبلين اتباعا فضلا عن كل ما يمكن ان
يصل للمقاطعه من اصوات البريديه حتى يوم
السبت وفق القانون طالما انه مؤرخ بتاريخ
الثامن من نوفمبر وبالتالي الصوره لا تزال
ضبابيه لن نعرف من سيطر على مجلس الشيوخ
الى ان تحسم المعركه هنا وفي اريزونا
وربما في جورج حسن همم
بالانتظار شكرا جزيلا لك فادي منصور مراسل
الجزيره من نيفادا
ومعنا من واشنطن ادولف فرانكو المحلله
الاستراتيجي في الحزب الجمهوري ومن واشنطن
ايضا جون نيفينقر مدير الاتصالات والاعلام
السابق في الحزب الديمقراطي معك سيد
ادولفو
رغم تقدم الجمهوريين حتى اللحظه ان كان في
مجلس
النواب او حتى
بصوت واحد حتى اللحظه بمجلس الشيوخ لكن لم
نشهد هذا المد الجمهوري الذي توقعاه
كثيرون لماذا كانت النتيجه
اذا صح التعبير باهته بهذا الحد
ت عوامل لهذه النتيجه
نربح في المجلسين بالتاكيد في مجلس النواب
لكنك مع ذلك انت محكمه التوقعات
وجود انتصارا ساحقا اكبر في الجمهورينا في
مجلس النواب وكذلك مجلس الشيوخ السببان
الاساسيان هو ان البلد ما يزال مستقبل
بشكل كبير وقد توصلت الى استنتاج ان قضايا
مثل التطهم والاداره السيئه لان استطلاعات
الرايه تظهر ان الرئيس يتمتعه فقط
تصل الى 39% لذلك تضخمه هو احد العوامل
العوامل الثاني مساله الاجهاض اعتقد انه
قد لم تحظى بالتقدير الكافي من قبل
جمهوريه هذا الامر ادى الى الكثير من
الزخم بين المصوتين
المستقلين وايضا
دعم ديمقراطين في حظوظهم بالتالي اعتقدوا
ان هذه هي الاسباب التي منعت من حدوث هذه
الموجه الحمراء
ما الذي يعني ما هي العوامل التي ساهمت في
تراجع الديمقراطيين بهذا الشكل وربما
خسارتهم لمجلس النواب ومجلس الشيوخ اذا
على ما يتوقع ضيفنا قبل قليل
يا عايزين
من السياسه الامريكيه انه عندما يكون
هنالك سلطه في البيت الابيض فانه خلال
الانتخابات النصفيه يخسرون المجلس هذا هو
التوقع
لهذه الموجه الحمراء اعتقد ان الحزب
الديمقراطي بشكل خاص اتى بالكثير من
الخطوط وقال اننا سنصلح كل شيء بعد مرور
سنتين لم يكن هنالك لا هي ليست في الوقت
الكافي لتحقيق كل هذه الامور والحصول على
نتائج نتائج
القيود على الاجهاض بشكل في امريكا وعدم
السماحي للنساء الامريكيات والعوائل
باتخاذها للقرار في مساله [__] الحمل ام لا
اعتقد ان هذا الحق كان مترسق وكنت كان
موجود منذ ان كنت طفله لكن ال- اا في
حقيقه الامر لم ياخذوا الخطوات المهمه هذه
السنرا اين القرار التي اتى من المحكمه
العليا والذي فتح المجال للجمهوريه
والمشارعين في انحاء البلاد بوضع القيود
على الحقوق وهذا عامل في حقيقه الامر تخطى
كل الحدود همم
فقد ان
اعتقد ان هذه القضيه قضيه مهمه للنساء
الامريكيات وللعوائل الامريكيات بشكل كبير
وكان هذا عاملا حاسما
ابقى معنا ابقى معنا سيد ادولفو ايضا
ننتقل للنسمع او
ربما هذه لقطات لكما لارس نائبه الرئيس
والرئيس الامريكي ايضا
بجانبها وهي تتحدث
طيب بطبيعه الحال الحديث يتركز حول
الانتخابات اعود اليك سيد همم
فرانكو الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب وجوده
في هذه الحمله هل كان برايك عاملا مساعدا
للمرشحين ام على العكس من ذلك
اعتقد ان الامريكان الكثير
ركزوا على وجود الرئيس ترامبو على ان
وجوده كان عاملا سلبيا لكن
السنتريس
الشماليه حيث دعم الترامب المرشحين وفاز
في الترشيحات
ايضا قام ترامب بدعم المرشح وايضا في
ارجوان
مخلوطه بنسبه 50 الى 50 لكن الفائز الاكبر
في اجانب الجمهوريه همم ليله امس كان حاكم
فلوريدا الذي قام فاز بها مش انك كبير
ويتمنى النظر اليه على
ترامب
اعتقد انه كان خطاب قد وصلنا للتحدث عن
المستقبل تحدث بلسانه
بدعم كبيرا من الجمهور ذلك الخاسر الكبير
ان الرئيس ترامب وانا ادعم ترامب لكنني
احسست بهذا الامر لان
حاكم سانتوس هو دعم هو لكنه لم يحضر
بالدعم بفوزين كبير وقد كان ايضا نفس
الشيء بالنسبه لي المرشح في نفاده
هل استثمر الحزب الديمقراطي الظاهره
الترانديه لصالح في هذه الانتخابات كي يحد
من مستوى الخسائر التي كانت متوقعه
اي برج
اوافق مع زميلي الدولفو على ان العنصر
الترامبيه هو الذي ربما له تاثير ثنائي قد
يكون يحظى بدعم
شخصيه ان الناس شخصيته تلقى صدا لدى
الكثيرين لكنه الامر قد لا يحدث بشكل كبير
ربما في حاكم فلوريدا لربما بسببي ادارته
بجائزه الديمقراطين لست متاكدا كيف
سيتعامل مع هذا الامر الديمقراطين ليس
بالضروره يفهمون
الدعم الذي يحفظ به ترامب وهما يفهمون
النقط السلبيه التي كانت في شخصيه جدا
ترامب وطريقه حكمه لكن سيكون من المدير
الاهتمام الطريقه التي سنرى فيها
الديمقراطيين وكيفيه وجوده في سياق
الانتخابات 2020 ربما يكون ترامب هو الم
اشرحها للحزب الجمهوري سيكون ربما احد
المرشحين الديمقراطيون همم لدينا رئيس همم
نعجب به على رغم ان انه قد لا يكون ذلك
شعور بانه يقوم بعمله بشكل جيد لكننا
علينا ان نتذكر اعمل السن بالنسبه للرئيس
اعتقد انه يجب علينا ان ننظر الى
الاستراتيجيات المستقبليه ايضا
[موسيقى]
مدير الاتصالات والاعلام السابق في الحزب
الديمقراطي شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا لادولف
فرانكو المحلل الاستراتيجي في الحزب
الجمهوري كان معنا ايضا من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
اعلنت ايران عن صناعه صاروخ فرد صوتيه هو
الاول من نوعه في اليوم نفسها الذي قبلت
فيه بزيارتي خبراء الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه خلال الشهر الجاري وكان مدير
الوكاله انتقد الصاروخ الايراني
ايران وهي تصنع العالم عن صاروخها الفرد
صوتي قبل تجربته الرسميه على الاقل تختبر
طهران ردود فعل خصومها تغني قائد القوات
الجويه في الحرس الثوري الايراني
يحلق بسرعه تزيد عن سته الاف كم في الساعه
اي 5 مرات سرعه الصوت يمكنه المناوره
او اعتراضه الصاروخ الايراني الاول من
نوعه رساله
الاولى وقد لا تكون الاخيره ولا يمكن
اخراج الخطوه الايرانيه من اطار المحادثات
لاحياء الاتفاق النووي المفاوضات المجمده
ومتعثره دون اعلان فشلها نهائيا ورسميا
سبق الطهران الاجتماع الفصلي لمجلس محافظي
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه الاسبوع
المقبل بالموافقه على زياره خبراء المنظمه
خلال هذا الشهر موافقه طال انتظارها من
قبل الوكاله التي تطالب باجابات واضحه عن
جزيئات يوران يوم عثر عليها في ثلاثه
مواقع خبر الصاروخ الفرض الصوتي لم يعجب
مدير الوكالات الدوليه رفع الكروسي قال
انه لا يمكن النظر الى الامور بمعزل عن
بعضها البعض وبان هذه الاعلانات تفاقم
المخاوف وتزيد الانتباهها الى الملف
النووي الايراني قائمه اعلانات ايران تبدو
طويله ومفتوحه لفتره ليست قصيره كشفت في
الخامس من الشهر الجاري عن نجاح التجربه
صاروخ قادر على حمل اقمار صناعيه الى
الفضاء وهو ما يثير في كل مره الغضب
الغربي المتبوعه بالتحذير من تطوير صواريخ
تحمل الرؤوس النوويه وهو مدى الطهران
علينا المؤكد ان كل صاروخ جديد مهما بلغت
سرعته لا يعجل بالتوصل الى تقريب وجهات
النظري بشان اتفاق النوويه يحتضر
من مدينه ليتس في انجلترا معنى دكتور علم
صالح واستاذ ديراسات ايران والشرق الاوسط
في الجامعه الوطنيه الاستراليه دكتور علم
مرحبا بك لمن تواجه ايران رسائلها
بالاعلان عن هذا الصاروخ الفرد صوتي الذي
نجحت في صناع
الغربيه
بالنسبه لهذه الصواريخ او او تطور
الصاروخي خاصه عندما لم تكن لدى ايران اي
اوراق او اليات الضغط على الجانب الاوروبي
لاخ- بعض امتيازات منهم فلذلك باثاره هذه
القلق تحاول طهران لكي تحصل على بعض
الامتيازات من الغرب او يتنازلوا من بعض
مطالباتهم ان نووي لدى ايران هنالك اليات
تقطيع اثنان فقط اولهم ال- ال- همم
التكنولوجيا النوويه وايران حصلت الى 62
كيلو غرام من من
اعتذر منك
للانتقال لاننا سننتقل لمتابعه كلمه
الرئيس جو فيدن
واتقدم الذي همم
احدث نوع هذه هي البرامج التي
التزمنا بها وهذا يظهر لهفه من قبل الجميع
لما نقاتل من اجله وعندما اعترينا شده
الحكم كان هنالك جائعه تعصر بناها
والاقتصاد كان يتدعها ولكن عملنا بدائه
عمل
ونحن نريد ان نبني هذه البلاد من قاع
الهرم الى اعلى
وطبعا همم العكس لم يبلغ الناس السياسات
الاقتصاديه استحدثت 10 ملايين ووظيفه
والبطاله
وصلت الى 3.7 بالمئه
القطاع التصنيعيه
يستحدتها 700 الف ايضا
الحمل حمله انتخابات نحن سنقوده العالم في
التصديع وسوف نستمر في ذلك
البارحه سمعنا بانها
التضخم انخفض في الشهر الماضي وعلماء
الاقتصاد يقولون ان هذه ايه ايجابيه
لصمودنا وستغرق الامر ووقتا
لتعوده
المعدلاته التضخم الى سابقه عهدها ولكن
نحن نركز على ذلك لكذا لذلك مررنا قانون
الحد من التضخم تستغرق الامر ووقتا لتطبيق
طبعا هذه الاجنده الاقتصاديه
التحسن في حياتهم اليوميه ولكن اعتقد ان
هذا سيحصل خلال اشهر القادمه وهذا ما صوت
الامريكان من لاجله سوف نرى سوف نرى جسورا
تبنى واستثمارات في الشبكه في شبكه
الكهرباء وايضا شقه طرقات
وسيارات الكهربائيه وتخفيض التلوث والى ما
هنالك وايضا الانترنت السريعه التي ستصل
الى كل منزل في امريكا
[تصفيق]
الى ذلك
عندما
يدفع المسنين الذين يعانون من السكري
دولارا فقط
[موسيقى]
55 شركه كبرى لم تدفع بنسا واحده في
السابق ولكن هذه الايام ولت
زوج دايزر
الان وهو يتحدث عن
انجازاته خلال سنتين من رئاسته الاداره
الامريكيه نعود الى الدكتور على مصالح
استاذ دراسات ايران والشرق الاوسط
الاستراليه الدكتور علم كنت تشير الى ان
صناعه الصاروخ فرد صوتي الايراني هدفه لفت
انتباه العالم والاوروبيين تحديدا ل همم
تلبيه مطالب ايران يعني نوع من الضغط لكن
السؤال يبقى هل همم الدول الاوروبيه
للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه هل
للولايات المتحده في هذا الظرف همم يمكن
ان تستجيب لايران تحت الضغط صناعه صواريخ
فرض صوتيه كما اعلن
مشكله الوكاله الوكاله الطاقه هي مشكله
مختلفه عن المشاكل السياسيه بين ايران
وامريكا والاوروبيين
مشكلتهم ثلاث مواقع
النوويه المشتبهي بهم حول نشاطات سريه
النوويه الايرانيه وهذه الشبهات يجب ان
تجاوب عليها طهران كما يبدو في هنالك
اشارات من قبل وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه
بان طهران جاهزه لكي تجاوب على هذه
الشيوخات ولكن المشكله الاساسيه عند بين
ايران واشنطن هي ليست فقط المشكله النوويه
بل هي توازن القدس قوه التوازن العسكري
وهذه وهذا هذا النوع من التطورات بالنسبه
للصواريخ الفرض الصوتي المتطور جدا ولا
ننسى ان قبل اسبوع ايضا ايران همم
كانت لديها خبره
لارسال صاروخ لحل الاقمار الصناعيه همم
ربما تصل مداها الى اثنا عشر الف كيلو متر
او تكون عابره القارات وهذا فلذلك هذا
التطور ال- ال- الكبير والواسع بالنسبه
للمشروع الصاروخ الايراني تغلق الارض
وليست فقط النشاطات النوويه شكرا للدكتور
على انصرف استاذ دراسات ايران والشرق
الاوسط في الجامعه الوطنيه الاستراليه
حدثتنا من ليس فينجر
[موسيقى]
هل الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم الفيفا انه
تم الاتفاق على تشغيل رحله طيران مؤقته
بين تل ابيب والدوحه طوال فتره بطوله كاس
العالم واضاف الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
الفيفا ان الاتفاق يتيح للمشجعين
الايطاليين والفلسطينيين زياره قطر وحضور
المباريات خلال فتره كاس العالم
باسمي بطوله كاس العالم انه منذ فوز قطر
بحقوق استضافه كاس العالم
اكدتنا جميع حاملي التذاكر سيكونون قادرين
على حضور المباريات في قطر مؤكدا ان اعلان
اليوم هو التزام قطر باحترام سياسات
الفيفا وبمتطلبات الاستضافه وقال مسؤول
قطريا الفلسطينيون سيتمكنون الان من
الاستمتاع باول بطوله لكاس العالم في
العالم العربي والاسلامي بموجب الاتفاق
الذي ابرمته الفيفا واكد ان موقف قطر
خلينا في تطبيع لم يتغير ولا يزالوا
موقفها مرتبطا ارتباطا وثيقا بحل القضيه
الفلسطينيه كما اكد انه تم ابلاغه
الاسرائيليين ان اي تصعييل في القدس
المحتله او الضفه الغربيه او غزه يمكن ان
يؤدي الى الغاء الاتفاق بما في ذلك
الرحلات المباشره
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الامريكي جوبيدا انه سيحثه مع
نظيره الصيني بينك خلال لقائهما في قمه
العشرين باندونيسيا مدى تعارض مصالح
واشنطن
واشار بيضا الى ان سياسه بلاده تجاهه
تايوان لم تتغير على الاطلاق
وكان
اريد ان استعرض معه الخطوط الحمراء
للبلدين وفهم المصالح الصيني القوميه من
وجهه نظره ومصالحين ايضا وتحديد ما اذا
كانت تتعارض وكيفيه حل الامر
لم تتغير على الاطلاق من البدايه متاكد
اننا سنناقش هذا الموضوع الى جانب قضايا
عده بما في ذلك حريه التجاره
كشفت بجين عن احداث اصداراتها من الطائرات
المقاتله والمسيره العابره للقارات اتى
الكشف خلال فعاليات الدوره الرابعه عشر
لمعرض الصين الدوليه للطيران جنوبيه
البلاد والذي شاركت فيه اكثر من 740 شركه
من 43 دوله
قدره على انشاء نوع جديد من قوه الردع هو
شعار بيتين في الدوره الرابعه عشر من معرض
الصين الدولي للطيران ومع ان المعرض الذي
يقام كل سنتين يشمل صناعه الطيران المدني
والعسكري فان الصناعات العسكريه اصبحت
تحتل الجزء الاكبر منه
حققه جيشنا في تطويرها
فضيحه ستار لاول مره عن المقاتلات الشبح
جاي 20 التي تلقب بالتنين العظيم وتملك
الصين نحو 200 طائره منها وبها غاده الصين
ثانيه دوله في العالم بعد الولايات
المتحده التي تمتلك مقاتلات من الجيل
الخامس
كما عرض الطائرات وين لون المسيره من
الجيل الثالث العابره للقارات والقادره
على حملي 16 صاروخا وقنبله اصدارات
مستقبلت صفقات اسلحه جديده للشركات
الصينيه
السابقه حيث بلغت صفقات الشراء نحو سبعه
مليارات دولار امريكي
العسكريه لاكثر من 50 دوله منها دول في
افريقيا والشرق الاوسط متفوقه بذلك على
روسيا لتصبح ثانيه اكبر منتج للاسلحه في
العالم
في معرض الصين الدولي للطيران وهو ما
يعاكس توجهها بيجين نحو تطوير منظومتها
الدفاعيه في الوقت الذي تتصاعد فيه
التوترات في مضيق تايوان حريق جنوب الصين
توترات دفعت بايجين الى نشر اكثر من 100
طائره مقاتله من طراز جاي 20 على طول
الشريط الساحلي الجنوبي لها مع تكثيف
الدوريات والتدريبات في منطقه بحر جنوب
الصين الهدف منها ان يكون الجيش في كامل
جاهزيته القتاليه امر ترى فيه واشنطن
تهديدا يستدعي تمديد حاله الطوارئ
المتعلقه بالصين
زمام مبادره الولايات المتحده او اي دوله
كل استعدادات القتاليه للصين هي استعدادات
لصد غاره وهجمه خارجيه
من استعاده بيجين لتايوان بالقوه العسكريه
تتزايد خصوصا بعد تاكيد الرئيس الصيني عدم
استبعاده استخدام القوه لاسترداد ما تراه
الصين جزءا لا يتجزا اراضيها شيماء شوقي
الجزيره تو خاي جنوبيه الصين
[موسيقى]
لن نتحدث مشاهدينا قليلا عن المشهد
العسكري الصيني حيث تحيط في انقطاعتها
التسليحيه بكثير من الغموض والتحفظ وتلجا
بدلا من ذلك الى استعراض قوتها الناعمه في
الاقتصاد والذكاء الاصطناعي لكن الجزء
اليسير الذي امكن لمراكز الرصد الكشف عنه
يظهر جهودا صينيه حفيفه لتطوير الاسلحه
ورصد مزيد من الاموال لذلك وفقا لمركز
الدراسات الاستراتيجيه والدوليه في واشنطن
تضاعف انفاق الصين العسكري خلال العقود
الثلاثه الماضيه نحو تسع مرات مرتفعا من
28 مليار دولار عام 1992 الى
245 مليار دولار عام
2020 وتراجح تقارير غربيه نجاح الصين في
الجمع بين نظامين صاروخيين يفقان سرعه
الصوت اعتمادا على نظام القصف المداريه
المعروف اختصارا باسم فوق
ويؤكد تقرير للكونجرس ان الصين اصبحت اكبر
قوه بحريه في العالم من حيث الحجم للقوه
بنحو 350 سفينه قتاليه متخفيه الولايات
المتحده التي تملك اقل من 300 سفينه
نووويا تتوقع وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان
تضاعف الصين حجمه سنه النوويه اربع مرات
بحلول نهايه العقد الحالي ليكون لديها الف
راس نووي على الاقل بحلول عام 2030
اواخر عام 2019 كشفت الاستخبارات العسكريه
الامريكيه للمره الاولى عن تقرير سريه
تطرق بالتفصيل وبالصور لقدرات الصين
العسكريه والاستخباراتيه وقد رصد التقرير
ظواهر اعتبرها لافته من ابرز هذه الظواهر
الزياده الكبيره التي تشهدها الميزانيه
العسكريه التي تحدثنا عنها قبل قليل مضيف
اليها بلوغ عدد الجنود الصينيين اكثر من
مليونين كما رصد تقرير الامريكي سماه
السلوك العدائيه المتصاعد للصين في بحر
جنوب الصين واستيلاها على جزر متنازع
عليها مع بعض جيرانها مثل فيتنام
والفلبين التقرير سجل ايضا تصاعدي وتيره
وطبيعه المناورات العسكريه المشتركه التي
تجمع الجيشين الصيني والروسي فضلا عن
انشاء الصينيين اول قاعده عسكريه لهم خارج
حدودهم ومقرها جيبوتي عند المدخل الجنوبي
للبحر الاحمر للحديث اكثر عن هذه القوه
الصينيه معنا من اوكسفورد جوليو بولييزي
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه المختص
بشؤون الاسيويه بجامعه اوكسفورد سيد جوليو
اذا اردنا تقييم هذه القدره العسكريه
الصينيه مقارنه بنظراتها الاوروبيه
والامريكيه همم في اي همم درجه يمكن وضعها
اكيد الولايات المتحده هي افضل بكثير
اذا ما قرنها بالقدرات العسكريه الصينيه
الان المشكله هي ان
التوازن في القدرات العسكريه هو لصالح
الصين اكثر واكثر فيما اقتصاد الصين يزداد
نمو في الاعوام القادمه ولكن
اذا اذا استمرت الصين على هذا النحو من
التقدم وزياده الترسانه العسكريه وحتى
النوويه كما يقول الكونجرس ان يمكن ان
تصبح مقارنه مع الولايات المتحده
نو اريد
ضروري انه يمكن مقارنه الصين بالولايات
المتحده لان الصين يجب ان تكون لاعبا
مهيمنا اقليميا ومن خلال ذلك يمكن لها ان
تقنع
جيرانها في جنوب شرق اسيا بان الصين هي
اللاعب المهيمن في المنطقه وبالتالي
سوف يكون هناك هذا التوجه من قبل الصين
الصين الان لاعب مهيمن على ال ال في
المجال الاقتصادي لو
ازدادت قدرتها العسكريه الا ياهلها ذلك
لكي تصبح لاعبا
اقليميه ودوليا على المستوى السياسي ايضا
والكثير من مكتسباتي الصين لا علاقه لها
بالقدرات العسكريه ولكن لها علاقه اكثر
بالقدرات الاقتصاديه وحقيقه انه من خلاله
ان الصين هي الاقتصاد الاكثر قوه اقليميا
وحتى عالميا يمكن لهذا ان يغير
تحليل الكلفه والقدرات في جنوب شرق اسيا
مع الجيران وهذا بالتالي سوف يؤدي الى
درجه من الامتثال
شكرا شكرا لك سيد جوليو بوليسي من
اوكسفورد عذرا للمقاطعه لانتهاء الوقت
[موسيقى]
واحدون في وجه الكوليرا ربما هذا هو حال
السوريين في مناطق الشمال الوباء يواصل
هناك حصد الارواح وتزداد اعداد المصابين
يوما بعد اخر وبذلك تتسع دائره المعاناه
الثلاثه نزوح ووباء وبرد قارس وفقر
والقليل القليل من الايدي المنتدى نهايه
الحصاد الليله تصبحون على الف خير
[موسيقى]